[Music]
[Applause]
and i've got alan shipnock he has been
covering golf for 25 plus years for
sports illustrated he has written
another book and i think this is eight
books that he's written it's called phil
the rip roaring an unauthorized
biography of golf's most colorful
superstar available online wherever
books are sold alan good to talk to you
again when's the last time you spoke to
phil mickelson
well it was earlier this year
you know
even after we had our phone call around
thanksgiving where he told me all his
secrets about saudi arabia
we were still in contact fills up with
the yellowstone club skiing
and uh you know phil never opens his
mouth without an agenda so he's
continuing to try to sort of
work the angles and
influence myself and other reporters on
saudi arabia and some other things
involving the tour so we haven't we
haven't spoken since since february for
sure though okay it's unauthorized but
phil still cooperated to do an interview
did he did he know what the interview
was for when you sat down with him or
spoke to him over thanksgiving
yeah there it's been a whole journey
because i actually went to phil three
times going back to the 2020 pga
championship and asked him to do
interviews for the book and
over about a five month period he molded
over and ultimately he said no
and which is his prerogative and i've
had so much access to phil and and his
the people around him for so many years
that
that was fine i just plunged into
writing the book and it was due december
1st so a week before the book was due
it's basically done at this point i'm
just adding another coat of polish
he decided to ring me up and
i think in the final analysis he just
couldn't help himself
you know it's been said many times about
phil is he has to be the smartest guy in
the room and it he just it bothered him
that he hadn't told me that he was
smarter than jay monahan the pga tour
commissioner and he was smarter than
greg norman the front man for the saudi
effort and that he he was working both
sides of the street and he had used all
this leverage to get all these
concessions he wanted and so yeah he
called me and
it was
i'm still somewhat baffled but in the
context of you know phil has spent his
whole career sort of manipulating the
media and he never opens his mouth
without an agenda and i think he in the
end he just couldn't help himself he he
had to try and get in my ear one one
time before i actually sent the book in
if he doesn't say this about the saudis
what's the headline
about this book
that's a good question because and you
know i've often thought like maybe it
would have been better if you hadn't
called me because it certainly has
overshadowed a lot of the other material
in the book which you know my goal was
was to write a really lively fun
anecdotal
balanced look at a very complicated
and contradictory character and you know
i think i did that like i said the book
was done when he called me um
and so
there was already some juicy bits in
there about his gambling about the bust
up with bones his career along caddy
about billy walters like
there was already enough energy around
this book that um there would have been
other headlines but uh you know
certainly this saudi stuff was was gonna
blow no matter what you know it was it
was happening and phil's in the middle
of it so this was going to complicate
his legacy either way but
um what made our whole conversation so
interesting and i guess so fraught is
that
you know phil said the quiet parts out
loud you know the golfer's been going to
saudi arabia taking their money now for
a long time and if you stay on script
you can get away with it i'm just here
to grow the game and i'm an athlete not
a politician everybody rolls their eyes
they know it's total bs but you can get
away with it
but phil would it was the few you know
the rare athlete to actually acknowledge
the saudi atrocities
and yet he so callously dismissed them
and there was a shock value in that in
those words but i think ultimately what
got him in trouble and sent him into
this exile was that he admitted to you
know these sneaky back room dealings
where he was helping the tour the saudi
tour actually got off the ground
and he was almost he was almost acting
as a de facto plane commissioner and
in that scenario he's actively
subverting the interest of the pga tour
and what so the words have gotten a lot
of attention it was really the actions
is what got him in trouble with the tour
and with his colleagues
the gambling part
40 million dollars
over a four year period is that accurate
yeah yeah that's reporting from the book
and
everyone's always known that phil's a
gambler like it's been part of his brand
and when he's won like when he cashed
that super bowl ticket on the ravens and
made over half a million dollars he
loves to crow about it but you also know
there's been some heavy losses because
it showed up in court documents and
press clippings and he's been he's been
linked to some shady characters through
the years but is this casino gambling
alan or betting on games
mostly sports betting but he does love
back rat and in the casinos and he will
go to the casino sports books but
it seems that it's mostly just making
bets through
you know bookies and
you know there was a whole controversy
the month after the pga championship
last year where phil was linked to this
mobbed up bookie in detroit um that
built him out of half a million dollars
and phil took umbrage to the uh the
detroit newspaper bringing this to light
and and threatened never to play in that
tournament again and so there's there's
always been this low roar about phil's
gambling but
we didn't really know the numbers and
you know as part of this billy walters
insider trading case he was subject to
this forensic audit explain billy
walters to the audience who's not
familiar yeah
if you can explain billy walters yeah i
mean that could that could be a long
conversation really walters is just this
famous
gambler and in the 1980s he was really
the first guy to apply computer analysis
to sports betting and he started making
money hand over fist and he's also a
legendary poker player he's the kind of
guy who'll walk into casino and spend 36
hours playing roulette and walk out with
three million dollars which he famously
did years ago
and he just has an incredible mind for
gambling and
because of all his activities he's been
subject to various indictments he'd
always beat the rap which made him a
folk hero in las vegas and
he also loves golf you know he's played
in pga tour programs he won the crowd
the crosby clan baked pro-am portion
back in 2008 so he loves golf he loves
gambling it was almost inevitable that
him and phil
would cross paths and they became
friends barely became a mentor and they
became betting partners and there's been
a lot of confusion about the role
between phil and billy but um
billy was not phil's bookie they were
partners and it was advantageous for
both of them because phil suddenly had
access to
the best mind in sports betting and and
now billy had access to the people that
phil would bet through because billy was
often getting cut off from his own
people because he was too good
and phil was not too good like um and
over time
phil would want to bet certain things
that billy thought were losers but billy
would place the bet because he knew they
were going to lose they would keep him
in good graces with the bookies and
sometimes he'd front that money and phil
ran up a tab essentially that ran at the
millions of dollars with billy that he
owed him and so now billy walters also
loved to play the stock market as did
phil
billy came into some some information
from um involving dean's foods just this
random stock but they were about to have
a spin-off and the the price was going
to spike
billy made a big bet on this and so did
phil and the question has always been
what exactly did billy tell phil
and
did phil know that this information was
tainted because it came from an insider
at the company and
this exploded into a big sec
investigation
and billy walters wound up going down
the river he got jail time he was
convicted on all the charges
and phil skated
he because of some some very complex
wrinkles in the law that i go into into
the book i won't bore your listeners
with now but
phil was not charged but he was named as
a relief defendant which means he
benefited from this bad information
they couldn't prove he knew that it was
bad but he had to give them the money
back and ill-gotten gains is my new
favorite term so we had to give back
over a million dollars to the government
and um billy has never forgiven phil
because he he feels like if phil
mickelson had testified on his behalf
that would have helped billy walters and
he may not have gone to jail that's you
know subject to debate but in in billy's
mind uh phil sold them out and
and so now billy walters is writing this
this his own his own book that's going
to come out at the end of this year
early next year um
whereas my intention was to write a very
fair and balanced look at phil mickelson
billy walters is not a trained
journalist he doesn't care about that
like he's got a vendetta and he's out to
get a scalp and so
phil is rightfully worried about what
billy is going to put in his book
because billy knows a lot of stuff yeah
i was told somebody who knows billy this
could be a flamethrower like he's he's
coming after phil i i don't know if it's
called this or there's a chapter it's
called it now it's my turn
and uh i i think he's he's coming after
phil we're talking alan shipnut he is uh
a golf writer the book is phil the rip
roaring and unauthorized biography of
golf's most colorful superstar available
online wherever books are sold i'm
always curious why so many people love
phil mickelson
what what is the charm what is the magic
well it starts with
he's he's an extrovert whereas whereas
tiger's an introvert so at a tournament
tiger has that thousand-yard stare he
doesn't look anybody in the eye he
doesn't acknowledge their presence it's
almost like he's performing a solo in
front of an empty theater and he doesn't
have to give anything more than that to
the fans you're just lucky to be
watching him and there's some truth to
that because he was so transcendent and
in late period tiger he's tried to give
a little more back with the occasional
nod but it it's very much he's he's
playing in in a bubble
and but phil loves energy the crowd and
he looks him in the eye he gives the
goofy thumbs up he waves to them
he lets them in and he's performing for
them and they feel that connection and
of course phil you know has signed more
autographs over the last three decades
than probably any human on the planet
that's just part of his work day it's
like he's going to punch the clock i'm
going to go sign autographs for an hour
and whether it's shameless brand
building or whether he really loves the
fans almost doesn't matter because the
fans are still getting the autographs
they're still getting that connection
he's joking with them so
it starts on a very human level
um
and then you know whereas tiger was this
this terminator this machine
with this perfectly sculpted body you
know phil has his his flaws as a golfer
and you cannot it's a high wire act and
it was more fun to watch because he
never knew he was going to you know set
himself on fire
and he looked like the fans he was a
little doughy he was a little pudgy you
know his clothes didn't fit quite right
and i think that some fans just related
more to phil even though he is this
uh you know trans transcendent talent
there was just this this sense of
you can't relate to tiger it was
maniacal werthac and his ethic and his
his ruthless excellence but you know
phil hitting these crazy ass shots and
and losing tournaments it just made him
more relatable more compelling on some
levels so uh and then there's there's
you know feels a rascal like he he's a
mischief maker he loves to stir the pot
and he loves he loves to talk trash
and he's always he's always applying the
needle and that's that's fun too like
it's
there's a great quote in this book from
charles barkley
where and he's one of the few people on
the planet who's been close to both
tiger and phil
and he says you know everyone in tigers
orbits up tight they're they're afraid
to say the wrong thing and he's like
under siege
and if you're with phil you're just
going to have fun everybody's smiling
and laughing like that there's just more
joy around phil and that's a pretty
fundamental difference and phil would be
gambling on the golf course checking you
know scores he used to pick games on my
radio show allen years ago and he
remember that he would call them
mother-in-law bets where he would he
would he would say to his mother-in-law
you should be betting on these games and
he was actually very good but you're
right as a as a former gambler
we only tell you when we win we don't
tell you when we lose help me understand
phil's not in the pga not in the masters
whose decision do you think that was
yeah it's very nuanced so after we
dropped the excerpt from my book and and
and phil got himself in some very hot
water and there was this very strong
blowback
uh partly because as i said you know the
sneakiness of subverting the pga tour
but also i think he failed to understand
that how emotional saudi arabia is as an
issue
you know that
and 15 of the 9 11 hijackers did come
from saudi arabia they did just
assassinate a washington post journalist
who is a resident of the united states
like they are bad actors on the world
stage and and their money is very dirty
and
i think phil just thought he was being
this cagey businessman who had had some
leverage and was trying to cut some
deals and he didn't realize how
distasteful saudi arabia is but does he
need money alan
well that that's one of the fundamental
questions in all of this because we know
he's made a fortune in his in his career
but how much has he kept
when you know
you lose 40 million dollars across four
years and again that's that's what we
know we don't know what we don't know
there's
there's there's other things in this
book that suggests he's feeling
financial pressure you know he phil sold
his gulfstream which is like his fourth
child everyone was shocked about that
and at the root of his bust up with with
jim mackay his caddy was money you know
that
he owed bones almost a million dollars
and you would why would he just make him
whole and even the billy walters stuff
it comes down to phil owed billy
walter's money instead of just wiring it
to him he had to he did this whole stock
transaction that got him in trouble like
again isn't he liquid enough just to pay
off his debts he would just assume he
was but
we don't know everything about phil's
finances we just have snapshots but when
you put them together it suggests that
um he might be feeling more financial
pressure than we could ever imagine
given what he's earned but it's not what
you make is what you keep so
um and that's that's been one of the one
of the the fundamental questions in all
this is why is phil chasing this saudi
money so hard
and
you know we might have some insight into
that through the book so yeah um well
where do where do we see phil surfaced
does he play an event does he do a
sit-down interview what's next for phil
yeah i mean there is a there is a
playbook you know for public figures
when they're they're trying to fight
their way back and
you would assume that he would he would
go sit on oprah's couch or maybe he'll
come on your show and and it would make
sense to start telling his side of the
story before he shows up at a tournament
but
you know that when phil put out that
public statement in february it was an
absolute word salad i mean it read like
a midnight tweet storm and it does not
inspire confidence that he has the right
people around him to guide him through
this very complicated moment so
and phil stubborn i mean there's there's
another quote in the book for peter
costas who was living out in the desert
and him and phil were friends and and
costas was kind of this low-key swing
instructor and he said
phil has always surrounded himself by
yes men and he's never in his life
listen to anything from anybody except
occasionally from amy and so
you know that's phil's personality he's
a very double down personality and you
see that on the golf course
the last hole the us open at wingfield
we want to hit a hero shot when he
should have just laid up and you
obviously see it in his betting life
and so now are we going to see it here
and this this first big controversy
that's that's really sidelined him from
golf is he going to try and double down
and prove that he was he was right and
therefore he is going to go to the
saudis and take their money and go all
in with the saudis
which i think would be a colossal
mistake from a public relations
standpoint but if he needs the money you
know they're offering them into the nine
figures
uh it's hard to say no to that but um so
there's there's some big things on the
horizon as far as the schedule goes
answer your questions the first saudi
event is in early june
and
pj tour members to go play
in an overseas event they have to get a
release from the tour
and it's almost like asking your spouse
for permission to cheat on them and the
tour said no and so now it sets up this
this intrigue or any tour member is
going to defy that edict and they're
going to bust a blockade and they're
going to go over and play in that saudi
event and if that happens they're
probably going to get suspended
and or they almost surely will get
suspended and then it's going to set up
a court battle on anti-trust and
this this could reshape the entire
landscape of professional golf so there
is a lot at stake and i think at one
point phil was kind of willing to be the
first guy out of the foxhole
but now maybe he's waiting to see what
these other players are going to do so
he may he may or may not play that first
saudi event the next week is the u.s
open which we all know is the missing
piece of phil's resume and uh he's now
back in the field by virtue of his pg
championship win so
early to mid june is is when things are
going phil's going to have to make a
decision if he sits both of those out
then we know this self-imposed exile
could last a long time
alan good luck with the book great to
talk to you again thank you yeah thanks
for having me dan alan shipnot uh he's
been covering golf for over 25 years the
book is filled the rip roaring and
unauthorized biography of golf's most
colorful superstar available online
wherever books are sold